but actually our our data are actually
expressions of our in a sense our life
force right like our data are are what
are being
you know spat out about us at all places
and all times essentially even even if
it's not on our phones it's being
triangulated on other systems
so we have to kind of think about data
as an expression of ourselves as human
beings and how do we kind of a
understand that and be protect that as a
right i think that's something i'm
trying to work on with multiple members
of congress
you know kind of conceptualizing data as
a as a right
[Music]
this week on forward ucla professor and
author of beyond the valley one of the
experts on tech's impact on us and our
lives ramestran of asan
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the ford
podcast author of beyond the valley ucla
professor surrogate for bernie and joe
and kamala i don't know how we pulled
that one off one of the foremost experts
on technology's impact on our society
rameshwar navasan welcome ramesh thank
you andrew thank you for having me i'm
psyched to join forward yeah worse like
to have you so
uh tell us a little bit about how the
heck you came to be
one of the world's leading authorities
on technology's impact you
uh you know came up as a student uh you
got your phd like when did you become
uh
passionate about this so i studied
engineering at stanford in the late
1990s right we remember that time we're
around the same age andrew you know and
and in the late 1990s um as some of us
may remember
there was a lot of buzz in within
silicon valley and stanford was very
much like a hub do you know any of the
famous people then who are your
classmates around then was like jerry
yang down the hall and stuff i mean i
some of the paypal founders were my in
my classmates you know definitely people
who were early in
you know early at google facebook etc
were classmates of mine we were all in
turman hall and the engineering school
together
and you know i andrew was actually
when i entered college was inner and
quite interested in philosophy religious
studies and art
um having you know first generation
indian american parents they told me
look like that's all great we love that
stuff too
but major in engineering or science or
medicine
so you can be so you can make sure that
you'll have a job after after college so
that sounds familiar ramesh i feel like
maybe your parents and my parents are
speaking from the same book um so you
went to stanford as an undergrad where
did you grow up also in california right
in the bay area i went to the same high
school as steve jobs and steve wozniak
homestead high school right near
stanford my dad was a faculty member at
stanford i almost went out to the east
coast i was really attracted by liberal
arts colleges i almost went to brown
except my dad said that
we don't want you to go to brown because
they don't give letter grades there i
don't know if that's true or not to this
day it can be true if you want it to be
that that is a true fact about brad so
not to
uh make it seem like you and i were
counterparts but
i
was choosing between stanford and brown
and would have gone to stanford if my
brother had
not chosen to transfer back east uh from
berkeley at the same time so i sometimes
think about the path not traveled where
if i had gone to stanford in the mid 90s
would i have become
tied up in the internet boom of the next
number of years probably not because
like you i was interested in philosophy
and
writing uh i started out as an english
major is one thing and i switched off
pretty quick from that after i read like
more flanders or something it was like
this is not what i need to be studying
so i switched to economics um but i you
know it's possible i would have been
caught up in the internet boom that that
transpired whereas you were an
engineering student uh so you were in
the thick of it absolutely yeah i was i
was applied math and industrial
engineering and then i worked in machine
learning and ai but the entire time
andrew like i was taking classes in the
social sciences both quantitative like
social network analysis as well as you
know anthropology philosophy you know
art history uh literature courses
because and i'm so glad i took those
classes i'm so glad i'm still kind of
the way i was back then in a lot of ways
um because i was really interested
ultimately my interests are always in
humanity in in in our in our species
and our planet and that's something i
actually
have always cared about way more than
anything technological obviously
technological interests or
literacies in technology are critical to
understanding uh our life chances as
human beings at this point in time right
so on every single level i feel super
grateful that i kind of came up in that
world somewhat accidentally
i'm very very familiar with the
tendencies of people within silicon
valley the ways a lot of engineers
function having had i also went to mit
media lab for grad school so i saw this
firsthand
and i always saw a profound
disconnection
between and it's partly our educational
system
uh between
the world of engineering
and the worlds that our engineering
we're going to impact and that's partly
because again as engineers we weren't
really trained to think deeply about
you know political questions social
questions cultural questions economic
questions definitely not global
questions
wow you've really got the programming
down pat um so i i again i'll i'll share
this with you where the
a lot of people know this about me so my
uh father and mother met as graduate
students at uc berkeley my father got
his phd in physics uh generated 69 u.s
patents my mom
got a master's in math and statistics so
i grew up very very geeky and nerdy
around folks that i thought everyone did
something in a lab as a job stuff like
that
and in my case i
uh went to
high school and college in new england
and studied economics and political
science and philosophy and american
civilization and a bunch of other things
i just found interesting
and then i went to law school which is
its own kind of coding and programming
and then i was a lawyer very very
briefly and then left and then did a
bunch of different things but what's
interesting is that i feel like my
multi-disciplinary
uh approach is that like i feel like i
get
what ordinary people are experiencing
maybe to a slightly higher degree than
than like some other folks who've had
similar rearing but i have kind of
like a structured thinking engineering
mindset to the problems that we have so
when i
wrote my book the war on normal people
it was like okay ai automation it's
coming it's going to get it but my big
challenge in many ways remission you
know i think you can relate to this
struggle in many ways was that i had
read books by technologists
like martin ford and uh
eric brynjolfsson and whatnot who had
written very effective
books rise the robots and the second
machine age
and i thought okay my value-add is going
to be that i'm going to translate these
things that they're
talking about to what's going to happen
to ordinary people
and so i remember talking to my editor
and he's like what's the name of this
book going to be and i said the war on
normal people
and then
then you know well i like it it's
provocative it's sensationalist so i
feel like you're similar in that you
understand the engineering brain down
pat i mean you have it you grew up among
it you got the degrees and credentials
and yet you still have this kind of
humanist impulse where you're trying to
bridge the world of technology and what
it's going to mean for
ordinary real-life humans is that fair
to say i'm absolutely a humanist on
every level i believe deeply in the
quite end that we should be starting and
and with the question of how do we want
to live as human beings how do we how do
we want to live as americans what kind
of world do we want to live in that's
the question that should guide
everything whether it's technological
scientific or otherwise right and that
love
of of of people and our planet which i
really have it's a really like personal
emotional you know almost spiritual kind
of thing for me came because i've
traveled all over the world i worked in
ai in amsterdam
i've worked in over 30 countries andrea
i've worked with
different kinds of communities in this
country i've worked with immigrants with
refugees with native americans you know
on so many different levels and so my
i would say my skills are far less as an
engineer though i do know how that mind
works and more as someone who can work
with people understand what they what
they wish what they want and build with
them right and so i would like to
introduce that vision into where we go
with this digital revolution you had
more sophistication than anyone else i
saw in the 2020 campaign and discussing
these dynamics and these issues
you know i was trying to bring some of
that honestly into the sanders campaign
because i knew he he was all about
you know the right the right things the
right p the right values i mean i
trusted him so much
um and and honestly
it's it's time for us to ask these big
questions and make decisions in the
collective interest rather in rather
than calling this out or that out right
this as you as you kind of are with this
for with the forward party it's time to
move forward and make decisions together
that are critical about the future of
data the future of ai the future of
surveillance and kind of data privacy
issues where do we want to take this
digital world because the digital world
as we know all too well as you know all
too well is not simply about using
social media or an exceptionalized
example like facebook the digital world
is in everything when we get bank loans
we go to the hospital the police
department the criminal justice system
or the lack thereof in my opinion they
are all mediated by technology data and
technology so any decision
about our collective future is partly a
question about technology and where we
want to take it
here at forward we think that your data
should be yours and that includes when
you surf the web i know you've noticed
not just one company is tracking you but
five
six
seven are tracking you and incognito
mode doesn't quite work
the way that you hope it will so how do
you actually make yourself as invisible
as possible online you can use
expressvpn like i do because expressvpn
allows you to beam in and get connected
and rerouted through an encrypted server
your ip address is masked no one can
track you there's no record every time
you connect to expressvpn you get a
random ip address shared by many other
expressvpn customers i know
it's almost too good to be true best of
all expressvpn is super easy to use it's
like you just beam into
another computer you even sometimes get
access to content uh that other people
have and you don't if you really want to
go incognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn that's visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang go to expressvpn.com yang to learn
more
[Music]
so you've worked all around the world
and the country with different
communities
uh you've been studying these problems
for the last number of years uh what has
been the focus of your research at ucla
this last number of years well a few
different issues so first of all i'm
very interested in digital rights right
so recognizing that in a sense our data
is not merely a a piece of property or a
commodity like my colleague um
shoshan azuboff writes about but
actually our our data are actually
expressions of our in a sense our life
force right like our data are are what
are being
you know spat out about us at all places
and all times essentially even even if
it's not on our phones it's been
triangulated on other systems um so we
have to kind of think about data as an
expression of ourselves as human beings
and how do we kind of a understand that
and be protect that as a right i think
that's something i'm trying to work on
with multiple members of congress um you
know kind of conceptualizing data as a
as a right
secondly i tend to work quite a bit on
thinking about how we might design and
think about technology in relation to
different kinds of communities in our
country and in our world recognizing
that many different communities have
different sorts of needs and values and
belief systems and we have to think
about how we design things like in the
rollout of internet networks mobile
networks but even platforms in that way
a third real issue that i'm really
focused on and i have been for over a
decade
is the relationship between digital
technologies and various forms of
people's based democracy right i know
this is something that you've been
kind of talking a lot about um so i ten
years ago was in like in the middle of
tahrir square i don't know if i told you
about this yet i was voting for al
jazeera i was there for three years
three summers writing about the
relationship between social movements
and social networks and and digital
technology
um and then the last thing and i think
this is actually probably the biggest
spillover of our digitally mediated
world and economy is the effect on
economics right and this is something we
talked about before andrew 25 million
jobs in the digital vein they're going
to be created within the next five to 10
years gig economy work seems more
precarious than ever i have students at
ucla one of the top universities in our
country who are in massive amounts of
student debt and are driving for uber
working for post mates these are huge
issues right like how do we deal with
you know this kind of unequal economy
that is being facilitated and amplified
and accelerated by the way technologies
are being rolled out right now and you
know universal basic income we've known
as you advocated for more than anyone
else i think um is is is good it's
important but there's a slew of other
possibilities we've got to put them all
on the table portable benefits you know
maybe people workers having different
some levels of equity in in app-based
platforms data cooperative ownership
arrangements
all right so you're well ahead of the
curve you're writing papers you wrote a
book uh and then at some point you hook
up with the bernie campaign how does
that come about well i have is that
rokhana rokhana reach out to you
it was row uh representative khanna i
met because i used to do some hosting
for the young turks who were friends of
mine i tend to take a very sort of like
conciliatory and positive sort of view
which maybe is not always the grip best
for like woke media you know it's a
little annoying to be honest i'm more of
a problem solver and a humanist being a
talking head definitely messes with your
behavior is because it's like oh get a
load of this person ramesh what do you
think and then you
you have to you have to be like oh
no i mean i've done it on cnn and so i i
know the dynamic well yeah so i so is
representative khanna and then you know
it just happens you know it's so cool
like in our lives you just randomly meet
people right like i met you through tai
who works with you you know and i and
similarly i knew faz faz shakir who was
um senator sanders campaign manager
when he was working at the aclu because
i was i was really interested in
questions of surveillance and privacy in
relation to you know hate against asian
peoples black peoples etc peoples of
color in this country and sort of
surveillance issues with that so i met
fawz randomly um you know and my i had a
couple of friends including my friend
jane kim who went to stanford with me
was the head of the california uh for
the sanders campaign which learning
you know and so
it just felt like this was kind of like
my world it's very surreal to all of a
sudden be in your mid 40s and to see
like you know hey there's andrew yeah
buddies are running this stuff yeah
around my age who's running for
president like this buddha judge here
like it's our like it's our time to take
over and show compassionate leadership
so i just want to be of service to
people i believe in you can help make
this world heal and make it more humane
and democratic
so you're working on the bernie campaign
and do they come to and are like okay
what are the big policies we need to be
pushing for technology because bernie is
aligned spiritually but he doesn't
understand tech i mean you know don't
begrudge him that so
um what
were the policies that you said okay
here's what you should be
uh integrating and what was their
response well my way of dealing with
this is i i had kind of written this
like long document i got to send it to
you called like a digital bill of rights
and and turned out that rokhano was also
voicing some similar language internet
bill of rights and his book just came
out which is great i mean i'm honored to
be in the book uh cited right before
you're gonna hover moss which was dope
um so
you know i was thinking about that i was
trying to send the people like at the
you know i'm not i wasn't like a
prominent person in the campaign but i
was trying to send all these ideas to
the people who were like policy
directors in the campaign i didn't get
very far man
um i was a little like okay um
but at the same time i was able to
funnel some of those ideas to
representative ocasio-cortez obviously
to representative khanna
and also we worked on one policy
together i was kind of more in the
surrogate role in fact one of my jobs
was to uh you know try to build bridges
with andrew ying supporters in the
campaign
good fun i i i'm sure it worked pretty
well because the andrew banks supporters
tend to like bridges
i hope
um we did work on one policy that i felt
was really cool um it was called the
internet for all program it was part of
the green new deal and what that would
do would inc and i love this kind of
stuff it would incentivize therefore
creating jobs and spreading
technological literacy it would
incentivize communities you know in very
rural locations and definitely native
american communities to build and own
their own isps internet service provider
kind of infrastructures as well as
mobile networks and the reason why i
think that's important is when we want
to talk about connectivity to technology
it's not actually just simply an
engineering question it's not just
connect or not in the process of
establishing connectivity there are a
number of interesting questions and
possibilities for people to gain jobs
like we've seen that in detroit right
detroit like abandoned now there's
amazing projects like the detroit
community technology project lots of
people are employed lots of digital
literacy skills which are critical in
education
happened so the sanders campaign was
attempting to do that i had worked a lot
with native american communities when i
was a phd student and a little bit
earlier in my time pre-tenure at ucla
and so i was also thinking a lot about
how how do we set up tribal
infrastructure so one of the good things
that happens with this infrastructure
bill that got through is it did support
you know universal broadband but it's
not simply when we use the term
universal do we mean verizon doing the
universality or att during the
university do we mean universality in
the image of people being able to create
their own
solutions that work for them and their
communities
we all struggle sometimes and it's
particularly true in the winter
sometimes you come back out of that funk
but sometimes you need some serious help
i mean professional help now getting
professional help is easier than ever
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy and i for one am super
pumped to let people know about what
better help can do for you better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and forward listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash yang
get yourself some better help today
you'll be glad you did
[Music]
so you referenced before that you were
in tahrir square what it made me think
was that there was a point not that long
ago and you might not have been part of
this chorus but there was a sense that
hey social media is going to make
uh democracy flourish all over the place
because it's very hard to maintain a
repressive
regime when everyone can have access to
things and organize and then people came
together
uh in the arab spring and toppled
various governments and were like wow
like democracy is going to bloom
and then that naivete essentially went
up
like uh
pop-up spoke like in the
weeks and months that followed where in
many ways
authoritarianism benefited somehow a lot
of the technology-enabled dynamics did
not improve things did you see that
coming like were you someone who was
like hey you know this entire facile
notion that more internet equals more
democracy is not going to work out like
people are hoping i i called [ __ ] on
that from the start um and the reason
why is because there was a narrative
that i consider neocolonial which is
that our tools liberate you right and i
knew fully well and we know fully well
that you know obviously this is great as
a sort of branding campaign for silicon
valley but we knew even at that time
that that you know various types of
quote-unquote personalization algorithms
were sending us into echo chambers and
you know these kinds of these kinds of
terms were known at the time and some of
my colleagues like eli parizer had done
work on that subject so i the reason i
went out there was i was super
interested a in that narrative and b
trying to actually not debunk it but try
to understand in a real way what
contribution of any are these technology
platforms having
in this massive social movement in this
revolution and and what i quickly
realized it was it wasn't that it's not
technologies that contribute to social
change it's what people do with them
that contributes to social change so in
in tahrir at that time in egypt at that
time
less about five percent or less like
robust internet connectivity one percent
or so of social media connectivity those
that were connected to those networks
were more demographically homogenous
upper middle class
generally liberal
more educated it turned out also the
iquan or the muslim brotherhood also had
robust connectivity and were really the
only organized form of resistance to the
hegemony of the state um and then there
was a very robust labor movement so what
i did is i pivoted around i interviewed
a lot of pretty radical islamists iguan
people i can kind of blend in and out of
things pretty easily
people super leftist this and that and i
tried to look at what were their
technological practices and here's what
i found out people were realizing they
could use social media to influence
journalism they could influence
journalists by basically posting
particular kinds of content on platforms
and getting that content not just
globalized in terms of having people
like see what's going on around the
world but also influence people within
their own country
journalists in their own country are dot
are looking at what these people are
posting on social media and remediating
it or what we call a media ecology
broadcasting it back onto satellite tv
because that's what everybody had at
that time and that was true in a lot of
the middle east and in india where i'm
my family's from that that's a fantastic
feedback loop that they discovered
they're like hey you know what we can
get we can get media coverage exactly we
can hustle this so i was interviewing
people like iman mohaldin you might know
him because he's now a msnbc anchor but
he was like the man al jazeera english
uh out there and i was looking at what
what iman was sourcing on twitter who he
was following on twitter and he was he
was strategically following certain
kinds of activists who were putting
stuff out and here's the other cool
thing that i saw people were pulling
things off of on online media like
platforms like youtube and projecting it
in public spaces i saw that all around
the country so that had another kind of
circulation of online offline and the
reason why that was important was that
could actually bring people together to
look at some of the documentation of
what was going on some of which was
manipulated content by the way very
propagandist and people would look at
these things and they would just rile
them up so of course blind technological
connectivity in a sense can dissent
disincentivize collective action but
certain forms of technological
connectivity combined with the use the
brilliance of activists who understand
their own country their own limitations
their own constraints
can make a huge change and so that was
really interesting to look at because
occupy happened right after that and i
was also studying occupy afterward yeah
you were right right there at the crux
of history it's wild around the same
time there was a similar naive belief
that now we have seen fail uh which is
that the internet was going to connect
us all to the sum total of human
knowledge and thus make everyone smarter
more enlightened there'd be new works of
genius because you you'd be able to
access everything at your fingertips
fast forward a number of years and it
feels like if anything we've gotten
baser
dumber
more misinformed
more angry and inflamed is this also
something that you kind of saw coming
i was with my friend tristan harris a
couple weeks ago and he called it the
race down the brain stem uh because
that's the way a lot of these social
media platforms uh operate uh was was
this something that you were concerned
about i've heard tristan talk about that
and i've talked to him about that as
well um
yeah it is because of two major reasons
well first of all on the kind of
democratic global level
uh we never really had that global
village because not everyone from the
globe was participating equally not just
with access but also in in content that
was being put out you know wikipedia at
a certain point of time and i love
wikipedia 95
of its uh editors and primary authors
were mail and and from the western world
north america canada europe and so on so
that speaks to how even an amazing you
know kind of
pla to technology like wikipedia
is actually highly asymmetric in terms
of who drives its content but i really
what we really saw was when this whole
personalization thing came up right so
the way google functioned is it used an
algorithm which we call pagerank which
basically said if we're going to rank a
bunch of andrew yangs with one another
we're going to pick the andrew yang that
has the most backlinks linked to it so
it was based on domain-based knowledge
what the the the epistemological claim
was
information that's most credible is most
socially validated or socially linked to
so if you notice none of that involves
spying on people right none of that
involved what but but then what happened
is personalization became more about
googling us
or socializing us on facebook right like
are we googling or being googled are we
socializing or being socialized are we
using technology or being used right
there's a sort of dyadic relationship
that is unexpressed and under discussed
still to this day
so when they started doing this
personalization stuff what happened is
we became googled and we became googled
not based on sort of a sort of
some sort of neutral notion of relevance
but based on what would grab our
attention and the way that works which i
think is really interesting is it's all
based on correlation so you know if you
andrew yang have looked at you know a
million web pages and i have all this
data about your engagement on those
different web pages which we call
documents in the information sciences
and then i have very similar profile to
you it will recommend content to me
based on correlation mapping it doesn't
actually know what content is
inflammatory or sensational because
we've never really done good ai work yet
to that extent i believe in text mining
so i'm being nerdy here but you know
please no dig in so um so it can't tell
whether it's inflammatory but it can
tell what i'm going to like is that
affair
what is going to activate and maximize
my attention
and we know
through and through and tristan talks
about this that maximizes that dopamine
release and that cortisol release
is outrageous content we like to you
know we don't like to get outraged but
when we see the former but we do
we don't like to be outraged but we kind
of do kind of do in this country
and the other really interesting point
that i just want to make you know again
slightly philosophical bent is what's
being fed to us online which is you know
in our present world and which will
likely shape our future in many ways is
all based on the past
i think that's really important to point
out right that our lives are being
directed digitally based on past data
of which we know nothing about we don't
know what data is collected about us by
whom how it's being monetized none of it
but imagine right andrew if your past is
like over determining of who you become
right to me that's a violation of
humanism itself so what you're
describing is
why when you google something and i
google something we can get different
results even if we're demographically
very similar even if we're politically
very similar it's no longer about that
it's about the data body that's the term
we use in engineering we call it a data
body uh which is sort of like it's a
triangulation of all these different
kinds of data points including data that
might not even be gathered again by me
on my phone or me intentionally it might
be data gathered about me when i'm
walking right down the street and i see
that amazon vehicle right out there
because those all have surveillance
cameras external surveillance cameras
yeah they can get us in the real world
too every once in a while or we'll do
something that says hey
um i used apple pay
at this storefront so it's like oh i
know it was there i know that there
there's like uh you know a buying
pattern that starts developing
[Music]
you opened by talking about the misuse
of our data as one of the main things
that you're concerned about were you in
on the
data rights
legislation
that was fashioned in california over
the last several years because
california really is at the
forefront of the frontier it's the only
state i know of that has a data
protection agency which i jokingly refer
to as like data cops like they should
give them some kind of really cool
uniform with some kind of futuristic
badge but like data cops here
uh and
no other states come close to that uh
were were you
um consulted by the legislators who were
drafting yeah are those rules obviously
folks in the assembly have talked to me
and a bunch of my other colleagues we
all um gave input on that i mean and i
actually have been talking to the new
york state assembly as well um you know
where you are andrew so about enacting
something very similar fantastic i i've
been advocating for states just copying
california it's like look you don't know
what's going on just take the california
law and copy it word for word your your
people will be better off yeah i think
it's pretty notable right even though
california is a hub for so much so many
of these technology companies that
there's a sort of robust desire here
also to try to balance things out as
much as possible and you know ro khanna
right is the is a congressman for much
of silicon valley right yet and he he
manages to maintain i i really find it
impressive a really both conciliatory
viewpoint birth is in his affect and the
way he speaks but also you know a
recognition of the need for
some significant uh changes i like
rokhana a great deal i think he's
uh on top of these issues in a way that
virtually no other member of congress is
maybe because he he does represent
silicon valley he's also got the same
kind of brain that
you you do or i do it's like kind of
this problem-solving engineering brain
yeah yeah not not as not as easily
uh inflamed
he's a very calm calm dude
um so i started something called a data
dividend project um that was trying to
energize people around the fact that hey
our data should be ours they're making
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
off of it it is a human issue as you say
i do think that it erodes our autonomy
our agency
it turns us into rats in a maze chasing
these digital breadcrumbs that we don't
even know
about because someone's trying to make
some money off of us
you have these quasi
states uh in
google
or facebook
and this was my attempt to try to say to
folks we can do something about it
the data dividend project does continue
to do great work
the eu is ahead of us on this front and
i'm also helping out an eu effort around
data unions uh that are
easier to make happen in the eu because
they have california type rules
uh and and so they're going to end up
being a step ahead of us
uh that all of that said i don't have
any illusions over the fact that right
now i feel like we're losing this battle
very very badly um i haven't seen
california's rules get enforced just yet
against some of these mega tech
companies many of which are
headquartered
uh in
the state
uh and some of the abuses and misuses of
our data i feel like are getting more
and more egregious all the time i feel
like uh i think
most americans can sense now when you're
getting some random ads or texts you're
like hey how the heck they know that i
was
talking about
going
someplace warm or whatever it is like
it's getting spookier and spookier for a
lot of people if you were
in charge let's change patterns for a
minute let's say that i had won the
presidency
uh and so now i'm the president of the
united states and then we say ramesh
what what should we do to try
and fix the house
uh what would you recommend in terms of
our data is it copy the eu type rules
like like what would you champion no i
mean this is thank you for asking me
that i i think first of all we need to
curb certain practices like the
retention of data so like for example
that certain first of all there needs to
be disclosure around who collects our
data who owns it and how it's being
monetized one two
so that's what we call collection of
data second is the retention of data so
like for example should data about me
when i was 18 years old still be me
available to whomever and you know we
don't even know who that is so that's a
huge issue because stuff from the past
could be used to influence your future
like i discussed earlier third is data
aggregation right i mean people don't
realize this but anytime you use your
credit card you're releasing what we
call a digital footprint when you go to
write in and have a rite aid card that's
where that data goes that's why they try
to incentivize you with discounts if you
buy if you if you use their dumb card or
whatever so it's so aggregation is a
huge issue because this is exactly what
you know shady organizations like
cambridge analytica who's steve bannon
was the vp of that company company was
funded by robert mercer who's a
computational linguist with multiple
patents from ibm speaks for itself you
know i mean and and they were uh
bragging about how much data they had on
it on 200 plus million americans uh at
the time of the election the reason why
that matters is not just because the
creepy way aggregation occurs that i can
have all this data so basically who i am
at right aid is probably different than
who i am on instagram which is also
different than who i am in another
aspect of my life and part of the power
of being human is we get to
have our own identity be
directed by ourselves in different
contexts right like when i'm in front of
my students i don't want them to know
what's with what my dating life might be
like or something like that right it's
like different parts of our lives but
they're all being aggregated and someone
like cambridge analytica i think it's
useful that that example is brought up
because they claimed with all that data
they could establish psychographic
models of human identity so it's not
that andrew you're asian american or
ramesh you're asian american it's that
you're neurotic around your kids at this
time in the morning they're mapping you
as a psychological subject not in a
stable way but it's like ramesh is open
in this way conscientious in this way
extroverted in this way it's called the
ocean model oco and and it's a complex
model of identity so these are all
things that on the level of data and
data transactions they have to be dealt
with but the externalities of this
digital economy meaning the effects that
are not simply about our screens or
these moments we're online are the real
issues right the the fact that you know
massive income and wealth inequalities
are all being shifted to you know those
who control the drawstrings of
technology look at the doubling of
wealth amongst the 10 wealthiest people
in the world many of whom are tech
people right bezos mosque etc right
zuckerberg
during this pandemic we are more
technologically dependent than ever
before so all of those sort of pipes
are being invisibly monetized and
redirected away from us so we have to
deal with digital economy issues i think
we need to identify jobs of the future
now we need to change our educational
system so they can work with those jobs
though as we know well education
shouldn't just be about training people
for jobs kind of unlike what my parents
had told me back in the day a little bit
it's also about what does it mean to be
human right and that's why the
humanities
and the arts are more important than
ever before so
economic interventions data related
interventions and um and interventions
on on the level of education it sounds
like you're
advocating a national digital bill of
rights that includes
uh ownership of our own data
and certainly
knowledge of who the heck is doing what
where our data is concerned is that
correct absolutely and one last
component that's important is involving
stakeholders in the design of various
algorithms so predictive policing
algorithms if they should exist at all i
don't really want them to exist or
facial recognition systems groups like
black lives matter should be involved in
the design of those systems and the
audit of those systems because we know
that many of those ai and algorithmic
systems have turned out to be racially
or gender biased or definitely
geographically biased so that's because
again not because the people building
them are racist or discriminatory yeah
it's just the data you put data into it
and then it's just going to end up uh
it's the same thing on the jobs front
too yep yep i've been reading a lot
about machine learning algorithms being
used to replace human resources work and
how they've been kind of having these
biases too so we got to introduce new
jobs of the future we got to transition
full-on to the to this you know
digitally mediated economy right away
which is you know digital media economy
doesn't just mean screens it means
automated systems are replacing amazon
workers uh whose data is being tracked
about all the time right so if amazon is
one of our main employers in this
country you know quite likely that many
of those jobs will be abso obsolescence
so we got to figure out what the new
jobs are going to be as a result so i
have colleagues you know some of them
tim wu and others who are thinking about
these issues oh yeah let's talk about
tim so to the extent the biden
administration has
a man on the inside that thinks the same
way you and i do it is tim wu uh wrote
very very
influential
books on data
uh like master switch uh and some others
uh brilliant guy
um he's a very very senior biden
official
who's meant to be reining in some of
these tech companies so i'm very very
eager
in terms of figuring out what he can get
done because it's the equivalent in my
mind um of like having you there because
tim thinks i i imagine he and
uh uci to ion i'm guessing 90 of things
um so what the heck is tim
going to be able to produce from that
perch because it's not like he's a
junior role he's a pretty senior role am
i right yes yes he does and you know and
also the federal trade commission has
lena khan who's his colleague at
columbia law school he was a big
anti-trust person apparently amazon is
as has kind of petitioned or sent notes
saying we're you know want to be recused
from any sort of activity or action not
sure where that went i was sort of
reading up on that i think that you know
there is a space for some sort of action
to occur from tim and and his colleagues
i haven't really been in touch or talked
to them much i'm not sure they're even
allowed to talk with us right i'm not
sure if they're allowed to talk to us uh
mesh but i'm also not sure what
we're waiting on like what are they
going to announce that's going to make
it happen i know there was some stuff
where like okay some of the tech
companies are a little concerned that
antitrust is going to be enforced
differently because
of lena
uh now
i was on the debate stage saying look
the
antitrust rules don't make any sense in
an age of dominant technology companies
a lot of these markets just flow towards
one winner
and so if you go and say let's break
them up and compete you're like well
kind of but that's not really going to
do the trick and like you're going to
end up just
uh replacing
one winner take all dynamic with
probably like multiple winner take all
dynamics and slightly different
categories
like it's just the nature of the thing
and what i said on stage was like look
no one's binging anything because no one
wants to use the third best search
engine
because all of the data is going to go
to number one you know google's a
natural monopoly
facebook and its products certainly like
an instagram whatsapp right both owned
by facebook meta etc are
yeah no one wants to be on a social
media platform that no one else is on
like it doesn't make any sense that's
right it's what we call network effects
there's no point of being on other
platforms when no one else is on there
so they might be better understood as
what we could call natural monopolies
you know you as a lawyer know about this
yeah and so saying like we're going to
have them compete doesn't make sense so
really what you need to do is get into
the guts and figure out okay what are
the problems we're concerned about with
this particular natural monopoly a
utility-based regulatory model is what
my colleague the pioneer and i have been
calling for we published a piece in the
journal democracy about why we may want
to look at these things as utilities now
the these things being these tech
companies and their platforms and what
if we were look to look at them as sort
of public utilities recognizing right
and we spoke about this before that
every one of these tech companies would
be values without an internet that i
guess originally 1969 we we all paid for
as american taxpayers neither of us were
alive then but
that started at boulter hall at ucla
right so so again just like the roads
that amazon monetizes for its delivery
vehicles are paid for by us there has to
be a public private kind of balance in
relation to this so we use a utility
based model recognizing that these
things have to have certain kind of
public utility to them and kind of set
our threshold definitions accordingly
you can legislate accordingly and i also
think just one quick thing that i think
is interesting is how there's bipartisan
and generally american people and you
know this with forward party like we
agree on almost everything i mean most
priorities we agree on yeah just need we
just need to implement those things
you know i mean i know that's what
you're trying to do it's like yeah yeah
let's help us let's just do those things
and one thing that americans agree on
and a lot of our uh elected
representatives is that the status quo
with big tech isn't good i mean and
republicans claim because of free speech
issues i mean whatever okay sure i don't
quite know if i agree with that but um
and we and and us progressives like
myself i i i think because i'm very
concerned with the ways it's it's um
partitioning and creating imbalances in
power politically and economically you
know and that's what i call it the
splintering of the american
consciousness i think that's the problem
that you can get everyone to agree on
maybe
if you can get everything out i mean you
know that it's kind of circular where
it's like the reason we can't agree on
anything is because our consciousness
consciousness has been splintered by the
social media companies parties are
internally corrupted yeah that's another
problem is you have
uh two corrupt parties in a corrupt
system and then each of them's like well
you think we're corrupt check out the
other side and then you know there are a
lot of people that are like oh yeah i
really don't like that other side and
then that if you come up and say like
hey maybe the lesser of two evils thing
is not really the way to go maybe we
should introduce a more dynamic
resilient sustainable system and then i
was like no no no can't do that i can't
do that because
because they're so
programmed uh it's a very it's a very
strange thing uh it's actually not that
strange in some ways it's predictable
but every time i run into
things like this it's like another
reminder
[Music]
so there are proponents of uh web 3
technologies that believe that it can do
away with some of the worst of the
abuses you're describing because
instead of a giant tech company making a
bunch of choices
uh you can have
those choices be distributed among like
a decentralize a decentralized
autonomous organization that makes
decisions based upon different actors
you can have a distributed ledger so
that instead of having a big tech
company saying hey
we affirm these transactions or like you
know this is kosher be like well
actually i don't really need you to do
that because
we can all just see it for ourselves if
we felt like it
so there are people that are
extraordinarily excited
about
the
potential of this next generation of the
internet
another group will say like hey you're
going to wind up with facebook metaverse
uh overrunning the thing in its usual
fashion it's gonna invest
i think i saw something like you know
ten plus billion dollars a year on this
thing
uh and make it so that it's uh zuck's
kind of disney world truman shift
remember yeah truman show where are you
in terms of your
enthusiasm and excitement level for the
vision and the hopes that some people
have for web3 well i think you know one
thing i want to say about kind of
cryptocurrencies and distributed ledger
technologies you know which you are very
in that world
is
i think it's sort of it is somewhat sad
that trust can only be established in
you know think about the claim that we
can only trust one another
when we are using a technology that kind
of guarantees trust you know because
it's it assumes that no one is
trustworthy right i mean just sort of as
a claim right
i what i what i i think that the idea of
technologies that can be truly
peer-to-peer as the internet was sort of
prophesized to be and was definitely in
its early stages
uh is is really important i think that i
can allow a lot of corrupt
uh third parties including those
platform providers to be bypassed but
also like for example imagine in a
country like ghana which i wrote about
in my last book and beyond the valley um
you can actually do peer-to-peer like
things on like land titles for example
instead of going through corrupt you
know
feudalists and etc right so these issues
can be very global in their scale and
they can be really peer-to-peer the the
aspect of it that i really
feel is sorely missing
is the community aspect of it right and
i really really want everybody to
remember you know first of all this is a
long time ago but there was no commerce
uh permitted on the internet i believe
until like 1998 or 1999 something like
that first of all
i'm not no commerce allowed no
commercial i mean i'm not saying that's
what we want but i just want us to
remember that was only like 24 years ago
or whatever i know it's so long i
vaguely remember the internet of those
days remember it was slow and clunky but
uh it also had kind of a purity to it as
like a lot of message boards
i i want to ask us that i want to ask
the question of if we were to transform
the internet into something that's more
communitarian where we all
use this or engage with this as a way to
also believe in one another work with
one another trust one another what might
that look like as a design experiment
right like that what does does that mean
we sort of give people equity you know
in platforms like even
even partial equity does that mean that
you know this internet is associated
with universal jobs
right it that's the question i'm very
interested or if we want to think about
digital currencies should they be state
and fiat based right otherwise they're
going to have so much volatility with
them as we've seen and become modes of
speculative investment right i
appreciate the rollout of web3 and
crypto stuff as a certain kind of
response
to this problematic troubling situation
that we can all agree on but i'm curious
if there is another shoe to drop that
can be more about a union
more about all of us coming together
that is really that larger question is
the question that motivates all
everything i care about
people coming together in respect and
compassion and trust and support right
across our differences
and i know i sound like a total like
civil rights hippie person here but it's
no you sound like a real visionary and
optimist even more so than me and
like inside than me right i mean you've
been in political uh
campaigns well so i mean so here's
here's where you and i differ in some
ways remash i mean i think you and i
agree on most everything um
and the the way we differ is that i look
at what's happening in some of these
environments and i'm like whoa that's
like really troubling very very nasty i
have a sense as to how we can make
things better as you do um but i feel
like you fast forward to
uh the way the world should be
even more so than i do like you take it
like a step further
whereas maybe because i'm so exposed to
the reality i'm like how do we make this
less terrible
yeah i mean you can envision the ideal
more naturally than i can this is the i
mean honestly total privilege of being
in a university and getting to be a real
free thinker and to and to imagine and
yes you're a free thinker you're like
unbound by
um
some of the very market-based realities
that uh i witness yeah and the other i
mean i'll just say the one other ass
issue or theme that's so important for
me
is is the care of our planet you know
i'm gonna oh yeah for sure but like
remember bitcoin mining uh electronic
waste with planned obsolescence in these
apple phones are they really any
different than monsanto seats i'm not
trying to gaslight but like it's kind of
the same logic right it's not well i
mean i think most people would disagree
with
uh playing technological obsolescence
and certainly one of the painful things
about
bitcoin mining is this incredible energy
consumption associated with it it's one
reason why you know there are some other
cryptocurrencies
that don't have that kind of
environmental impact which is something
i applaud we you know i've been trying
to push right to repair
uh legislation i've worked with a couple
like state assemblies in michigan and
other places to try to get that to
happen one of the coolest things i've
seen all around the world uh andrew is
i have seen
how in places like kenya and nairobi
i've seen it in mexico city i've seen it
in india i've seen it right here in la
especially like kind of toward the south
part of downtown where it's more like
barrio you know people are repairing
everything recycling everything
everything is being kind of combined and
what i've seen in like nairobi or in
addis ababa in ethiopia is people taking
taking transistors out of like old
computers and kind of remixing it
macgyver style with like you know thing
with digital electronics and so i just
think that there are these kind of
secondary and tertiary informal
economies that are really important to
recognize that are sort of the offshoot
of this digital world and they've
existed of course in the in the
industrial context as well but i think
that again the more we can kind of
facilitate policies and and give voice
and and inspiration to the creativity of
people so here's why i'm an optimist i
really do believe in the creativity and
in a lot of ways the goodness of people
and i've seen it and i really think that
most people are are like that you know
and i saw you tweet something like that
like yesterday like there's good people
everywhere something like that you know
yeah um and and i agree with you one on
the power of creativity
uh and two on the need to build
communities
in multiple ways which i i would suggest
includes offline as well as online i
mean i accept that we're going to be
doing a ton online but i do think that
there's something
very
intrinsic and human about people getting
together
and forming bonds and connections face
to face
um
i'm
i i'm also
invigorated by some of the
things that i i see that are a little
bit less conspicuous i mean one of the
dark things about the present time is
that if you go onto social media like
you can get exposed to some very very
terrible things very quickly and you're
like oh
like this isn't that good
it's one reason why i
try to keep my stuff really positive
because i feel like there's negativity
in a lot of other places
yeah yeah i mean and remember also like
that world that's being fed to us by
social media is likely to
computationally select you know
algorithmically select content will rile
us up you know i've been trolled online
not probably nearly to the extent that
you have but i've done it you know i've
had a lot of that come my way and then i
you know this is a very personal thing
but i just can i i've developed a lot of
practices where i can just sort of like
i'm about this so i can just sort of
like sit with things and and look at
them and see like am i is this really
real is this really affecting me and how
do i want to engage with that right and
and in a sense remember the logic the
computational logic and cadence to these
technologies are always on
multi-channel
multitasking
and they're overwhelming and
disorienting i mean this is literally
what neil stephenson wrote about in his
description of the metaverse in his book
snow crash right from like i remember
snow crash hero protagonist what a book
i loved that book i loved william gibson
and him and i used to read all that
stuff and it was like you know like
blade runner style a little bit and then
yeah neuromancer that those books wow
were though they groundbreaking at the
time like you read them and
most of what they predicted came true
it's up for yeah sci-fi is very helpful
as a text so it's like
again remembering like what is it what
do what does it mean to be human how do
we want to live as human beings and and
one thing i'm really thinking about and
writing about i might write a new book
that is philosophy but you should write
a new book period but continue okay yeah
please you know i would love your your
your advice on that um is about how
about borders and bordering right so
like biometric technologies border us
because they partition us into data
bodies right meaning technologies that
are gathering physionomic
input right or physiological input
space now has become this new border for
those who have and those who have not
notably interesting how those who are
the most wealthy in the history of the
world are so obsessed with space right
that to me speaks to a certain kind of
fatalism and negativity about our planet
and its people right
and and and really generally when we
want to think about knowledge itself and
different cultures in the world this
idea of borders is no long is not as
sort of
cutthroats right um you know in the
world who gets to move in the world and
who doesn't right like why is
sub-saharan uh
african immigrants drowning in the
mediterranean or the way things are in
our border here so you might think like
why is ramesh talking about this i'm
really interested in thinking about that
in this digitally mediated world right
like so
if if we are to think about technologies
again that where borders are more about
people communicating with one another
and negotiating relationships rather
than this so i really want you know
anyone and everyone who's listening to
this to work with me on this like i
really want so like it's not just about
reforming or oh we got to deal with this
problem or background from little things
here and there
kind of like the way our political
system works this kind of anxiety driven
political system we have but i want
imagination and transformation also to
be part of our blueprint amen that's
glorious ramesh how can people
find you uh and keep up with you so i'm
on twitter i'm not so active on social
media for my own like personal mental
health but on twitter i'm ramesh media
r-a-m-e-s-h-m-e-d-i-a
i'm hoping that i can get on to other
podcasts you know some of the ones you
mentioned to me when we talked before
andrew that i can keep sharing these
ideas and these visions
um people can take a look at my book you
know which i wrote as a crossover book i
wrote it with mit press but i really
tried to write it like a journalist that
was a great exercise for me it's called
beyond the valley yeah and that was a
real honor to write i wrote a little
about you and dividend about the
dividend programs and universal basic
income
in there i talked to michael tubbs who
had been running those ubi experiments
great guys yeah i met mike like
almost 15 years ago at a ted conference
and he was like 22 or something and um
you know it's it's yeah
and i think more than anything i just
want people to know like i'm
i wanna i i'm like inspired and excited
and so you know you i'm not like some
kind of elite who won't he's really not
people uh ramesh is
a beautiful human being uh and a true
positive visionary
uh so
godspeed ramesh you and i will just keep
on fighting for a brighter future and
with someone like you
uh helping show us what it can look like
we have a much better shot at getting
there i hope so you know i mean we're
all in it together that's the thing we
got to remember we're actually all in it
together right it hasn't the pandemic we
are all in it together we're all in it
together and we gotta gotta just we
gotta come together and pull together
and try and get some
real
uh solutions across the table we sure as
hell can do it though we sure as well
amen let's go thank you so much ramesh
thank you such a pleasure and privilege
thank you for having me
[Music]
you